oh [ __ ] these screens suck hey there's
my uh cocktail there
oh what do you got what are you drinking
i went with a cos amigos
ooh because i got the bottle as a gift
uh for a birthday present and it's a
great tequila
and we drank it all night one night uh
at the
the fat black me you and i think maybe
ari and mackie a couple people came in
and out oh man and we've got so hammered
we walked outside the sun was out
and then the next day ever texted you at
like six and you're like dude i'm in so
much pain i'm like me too i've been
puking all day
my head is killing me oh dude those were
like those felt like
grungy rat pack nights where
we we'd like we'd be trying to leave and
and you'd be like ah i gotta go i just
got off the road and one of us would be
like one more drink
all right what the hell you know exactly
because like we used to get shit-faced
together all the time we were in our 20s
we had more time but then we started
getting busier with the road and
you're doing sets here i'm doing sets
there so when we got together it was
like
we couldn't leave each other you know we
had to just keep boozing yeah you like
you
look for the you look for the hang it's
like when you're young comics when you
open micros you get that every night but
when you're
when you're older and you're on the road
you don't you don't see your friends as
much so you're like [ __ ] we got one
night
to do a week's worth of drinking exactly
exactly yeah and then we got free drinks
because it was the
cellar and oh man it was just a lot of
late nights and yeah you got to pack it
all in that's what's so hard about the
pandemic
is i mean obviously this the comedy part
sucks but the hang
like we just set this table for hours
and it was like therapeutic and then
now that's why we do this [ __ ] dude
you're so right and that was the thing
about the comedy cellar is that
they wouldn't kick us out so we'd be
around the corner with the fat black
[ __ ] cat
and we looked down our phone thinking
it's 2 am and it'd be 6.
like constantly we're like because
there's no windows they just block off
the door so it's like you may as well be
in a casino at that point you're just
like i'm just drinking there's no time
anymore
no time it's all free and then liz the
person who runs the cellar lives two
blocks away and she's a booze bag
so if we're drinking she's like great
and she wants to get drunk so she'll
keep it open
later you know it's 5 a.m no one closes
liz will drink dirty martinis out of a
pint glass
like a boss she is yeah but that's
that's where like a boss comes from
maybe
you drink like a boss bosses yeah you
have to drink
yeah because she's got all that weight
on her show the scheduling and the tv
stuff and the annoying comedians
bothering her so when she god she has
the the the chance to tilt one she's
going to do it
she's trying to have a drink and some
comma comes in like did you see my tape
she's like [ __ ] off
exactly every comic the the comics that
walk in and shake
every [ __ ] hand will covet stop that
i know jesus christ enough with the
handshaking even even in the movie
comedian seinfeld's like we just shook
we got it
it's not just a networking thing it's
like a thing of a drunk
sure because like drunks will like shake
your hand and like do it and like we
just shook come on
right what you get one shake one shake
it's it's kind of an acceptance thing
like hey guys i'm here
you you accept me i you know you barely
know me but please
shake my hand that means i'm in yeah how
about you earn you're in how about you
say something funny or or grab us
that's just a shake because you're using
social norms
as a way in you're kind of abusing it
yeah
it's tough it's tough it's tough
because we're already uncomfortable so
when you're put in the uncomfortable
position we're just like all right we're
in whatever you need to make this go
away
right right i know it's it's tough but
by the way cos amigos george clooney
right sold it made like a billion
dollars on it
unreal who would have thought the liquor
biz was the way you know it's like jay-z
and puff daddy and uh sammy hagar all
like made zillions off of liquor we
should we should make a liquor
brand and like just try to just on the
chance that we pop
yeah yeah i mean we're not gonna click
we're not gonna pop like clooney but we
might pop
enough right i mean
the rockers got killed the difference
well the rock has terra mana that's the
big one
i got that in the freezer it's pretty
good what's taramana it's like another
blind
it's like a blanco uh tequila silver
uh got him i totally would i say blanco
uh quite his character
[Laughter]
the rock has uh terraman it's good and
then
remember corolla had mangrove does he
still have that still has that
he's got bros a was another one yeah i
think he cleaned up on that [ __ ]
i'm sure yeah it's a good move
yeah i mean you get something it's like
normalizing a kind of [ __ ] drink
but you put it right a man thing in
front of him though yeah we could have
it
you know also oh sorry my [ __ ]
computer's being weird
yeah also it's like it's a genius sale
because
if you like if you're a fan of a guy
he'll buy his [ __ ]
and everyone wants to drink anyway so
you get that perfect like
tiger woods sells a watch i'm not gonna
buy that watch
even if i like him but yeah i still need
a drink
so it's a pretty smart investment i'll
tell you the tiger wood sells a lube
i might listen something about something
sexual he could get me to bite because
he is a legendary poon hound
oh one of my old jokes tiger how many uh
supermodels did you [ __ ] tonight
four all right
all right remember giraldo dead a bit
something like
uh how like how peop they don't
understand sex addiction but like
i bet like to his wife he was like
there's some things that i bet you don't
understand like you know
like i don't understand your obsession
with shoes but if a
pair of free shoes knocked on your hotel
room door every night
you might keep a pair like oh that's a
[ __ ] great angle to like defend
the cheating great angle yes so good
so good the geraldo val a valedictorian
of columbia university
what is it yeah i mean brilliant guy
such as the same regis
do you ever get bummed that we don't
like we didn't get to hang out with
geraldo with the seller
a little bit yeah but i think he was a
little squirrely
like i met him once or twice because i
was such a fan and i like paid money to
go see him at gotham
once and dude do you remember yeah i sat
next to you a comment oh that's right
yeah
yeah it was you and me and we and we uh
listened
uh my friend was recording the set my
friend ellie was recording the set
and he couldn't listen to her because
every other joke one of us would be like
oh
[ __ ] that was amazing
ah that's great yeah yeah he was so
fun but like liszt has this famous story
about you know
20 years ago over david tell in
maine or some crazy thing and david
tells like we're drinking tonight and
i'm gonna drink you under the table and
this was like
i'm 20 years younger than you i'm a
boston drunk let's bring it on
he said three hours and he was like no
more no more
please sir please i'm sorry and i think
i think geraldo was the same way
liz is like the kid in unforgiven who's
like i could murder a guy
and tell us what like you don't want any
part of this [ __ ]
exactly yeah this is another level there
i'm way more of a drunk and a deviant
than you
plus i think there was some blow
involved and all that so you couldn't
keep up with
with dave's he's the yoda of jokes and
drinking
he's like yoda meets hemingway because
there's like there's like a
there's like a yeah there's like a
lyrical nature to his humor and sit
and uh and but then also the drink and
you're like [ __ ] i i didn't
we didn't know a towel when he drank we
didn't we knew him
since he's been sober he's still [ __ ]
brilliant but uh
yeah i know him uh
dane cook never drank oh nick griffin
was a booze bag apparently
if you don't know nick griffin look him
up right now if you're watching this
because
what 11 or 12 of the best letterman sets
you've ever seen if you like
jokes watch nick griffin unbelievable
great writer
i see him at park shows and [ __ ] like
he's out there he's writing new joke
have you heard his jokes on the couch he
has a chunk on couch oh dude he's the
best
it's a killer i love his joke where he's
like uh
he said these celebrities they're always
complaining the paparazzi's bothering me
oh yeah
visa's bothering me
[Laughter]
so good yeah he's got those bits about
how like
brad pitt complains uh kill for those
complaints i mean he's
he's killer he's one of the best but who
knows this business is all topsy turvy
his life is topsy-turvy man it's all
good i'll tell you what i'm drinking
because uh oh please you told me
i love the casamigos choice love tequila
it was between tequila
and scotch tonight for me uh those are
my two
those are two i like doing a little wine
in the winter too little red wine
oh yeah why not but uh i don't even know
what this
is it's my age our old agent hilary
robbie got me this it's a nice scotch
wow
i don't it tastes delicious it's really
really good is it pd
is it uh it's a little pd it's not that
it's not like super i mean [ __ ] man
those i love a good like
like lagavulin that's the [ __ ] right so
good so smooth yeah
that was like that gave amy schumer
major points that that was in her rider
that i'm like oh she she [ __ ] drinks
petey scotch
right i know that shit's amazing just on
ice
or neat so good no it's just a really
it's just really smooth it just doesn't
even taste like i mean
the [ __ ] will still give you a hangover
brown liquor will still [ __ ] me up
that's why i was a big whiskey bourbon
rye scotch loved all that [ __ ] but bert
told me that
a tequila is or maybe it was ron white
tequila is the only
liquor that's an upper and it's
a better hangover because it's clear
yeah no i'm sure i mean this
you got to go easy with the brown stuff
these days but uh
damn dude it is it is good like i do
like this [ __ ] and
it is fun to like look through your
liquor cabinet and realize like
oh like your reps just like there's i'm
never gonna go through all this [ __ ]
that's so like that's such a like
agent gift they're like here's a bottle
of scotch i'm like perfect
yeah and it's such a weird thing that
they're like hey keep your life in order
make us money but here's poison
it's a weird message but hey i'll take
it i mean
it also kind of shows we don't actually
have a problem like we like we like the
sauce
but i got a full bar card over there and
i don't hit it
that often so if we had a problem they
wouldn't get us one nice bottle they get
us like eight shitty bottles
right yeah that's the problem the guy
with the [ __ ] nips
you know those minis hey that could be a
[ __ ]
like is it you're somehow more of an
alcoholic if you have less
booze oh i mean that was like a thing i
remember
bukowski had that book uh hollywood
because they made that movie bar fly
where mickey rourke is basically playing
bukowski
yeah i think in one of the scenes he
like took a sip and like didn't finish
it and he's like that's
[ __ ] a drunk always finishes it ah
there you go he's calling out me by the
way mickey works probably like i know
what a drunk does
i'm struggling here like clearly the
guy's got some baggage you know
but uh what happened to that guy he was
like the biggest
he was a great actor he was like a huge
a-lister hunk
like sexy guy out of the gate like this
james deeney kind of brando
quality so handsome so handsome and then
now he's like this weird
ghoul plastic surgery nut well he he was
you know i think a damaged guy very uh
like super handsome great actor and then
was like i want to be a boxer
you know he was like the logan paul of
his day
wow so he he would box people and i
think he could fight but he's not like a
[ __ ] pro
so he got his face pretty badly [ __ ]
up and
uh got some plastic surgery and i think
that's when it begins
and i think that's why he he looks how
he does i think he would age
much better than wow that's fast and
it's also interesting that like he tried
to get back and acting when his face was
[ __ ] up so his agent when they got the
wrestler was like
finally we got a gig for you where you
can look like ass
and you look like you've been mangled it
was a perfect gig
that's a great agent it's a great movie
great movie great there are a lot of
comedy uh parallels in that one too oh
my god right when they're like
you see how they're like bonding the old
wrestlers like oh [ __ ] that's comedy i
like the
at the [ __ ] uh autograph signing yeah
that's that's comics like
texting on cameo like are you on cameo
right whatever
whatever yeah and they're doing you know
they were comparing like i got three
ribs broke and i broke my ankle
that's like us like i bombed here i lost
this
this tonight show gig i [ __ ] that one
up i lost that tv
pilot whatever it is yeah our scars are
emotional
that is like um do you ever like were
some of your early jokes about drinking
you you have so many drinking jokes
yeah so many you write what you know uh
and i
i secretly wanted to be like this
romantic drunk comic
but i think you kind of grow out of that
yeah well you either got to live it or
you got to grow out of it because like
the
the
drinking comic is cool in their 20s but
then like you hit your 40s or 50s and
you're like
this is like this is a choice at this
point right
right this is who i am yeah yeah i mean
no offense to bert but i that's gotta be
a bit of a
monkey on your back like all right i
gotta get [ __ ] faced now and i'm i'm
pushing 50 whatever like that's tough
well yeah worry about the guy yeah i
mean he's it's weird he's super healthy
in some ways
i know i know he's [ __ ] i went on a
ski trip with the guy he outskied all of
us
no he's like an athlete it's people
laugh when when when i
say he's an athlete oh i know he's like
an athlete he's like a big
athletic guy you know totally like he he
would uh
out-ski all of us and then second day he
was like you know i'm gonna try to
snowboard and then he snowboarded better
than all of us
and then ari's a good skier he's like
i'm gonna race you ari fell
broke his wrist burgess flew by him
and then he works out every day i just
realized by the way i'm sipping
a really expensive scotch out of a
syracuse funny bone
cup notoriously my least favorite club
oh it's terrible i'm banned from a lot
of the clubs because of that
they they really work me for what i mean
first off
i'm trash i don't deserve this scotch
clearly but uh
no this is yeah i did whatever like they
were
my agent called me they're like what did
you like what did you do
they're furious and i'm like my axe i
don't [ __ ]
like i didn't do i didn't do anything i
didn't like melty i know she's picturing
i melted down on stage like [ __ ]
all of you it's like first off it's a
mall in syracuse it's not like our ideal
audience like we didn't
get into this to [ __ ] perform next to
a cinnabon and spencer's gifts it's not
like where comedy lives you know
right yeah it's actually next to a toby
keith's
that place was a soul crusher the hotel
was weird the town
sucks the people suck oh man i hated
that weekend and that's that's a
a real your opener is going to do better
than you weekend
yeah cause my opener was always some
hack ah [ __ ] i'm just now i'm trying to
think of
i know anything i had a funny guy
opening for me for sure okay
uh it was brenter hewn who's really oh
he's great he's really funny
yeah he no he both like had ups and
downs so i mean it was like
uh i've heard stories about that club uh
where they're just the way steph was
just talking so loud
yes people don't get what's driving us
insane with the weight staff just
talking so [ __ ] loud
and uh i guess it was ron on hershberg
our buddy
was featuring there and ali sadiq
was oh yeah who every clip i see the guy
he's funny as hell i don't know him but
like he's a killer and he sells out he's
he's great
he's really funny and ronan said like
he's just on stage
not huge crowds he's uh
having to talk over the weight staff
that's being so loud he's just looking
at them and he goes i hope you
[ __ ] know you're doing nothing
for me he just starts turning
not on the crowd on the wait step and
i'm like oh my god
it's like it's the weirdest thing
because you're like we're kind of on the
same team here we're both
employed by this club at the moment and
you're killing me and they don't know
like they have to do their job but it's
not their fault
they're usually not if that's the case
they're usually not properly trained for
that
right they should know but uh yeah i
mean that's just not
a good gig no no it's fascinating how
like
just the same material can kill in one
city and then you go
20 minutes over like buffalo i do great
and then you go to syracuse
that's a great point buffalo is great
syracuse i did a good club there once
um but you know the funny bone for some
reason i think they just papered so
no one paid for their tickets so you get
a lot of those and then uh
because i didn't sell enough and then
and then uh
yeah it was just one of the also like
the highest suicide
per capita i think in the united states
i could be wrong but i think it's
up there i think it's like in the i know
like i know that there's a very high
suicide rate
interesting i i could see it i mean it's
just blistering cold there's nothing to
do
and it's one of those towns we go what
should i do here and they all say the
same thing dinosaur barbecue
like you got a barbecue joint that's it
that's the height of culture
in this town that in basketball like
their college ball is pretty big
they got a cool college ball situation
but yeah it's
and i should say my comedy there did not
do anything to help the high suicide
rate i think
[Laughter]
but yeah you're right dynasty i know
like i've been to the games there it's
pretty cool
the the arena is pretty cool and like
they do recruit well because they're
like
you get to play in front of a shitload
of people they're you're the only show
in town so like right
they recruit but it's like yeah it's
you want to say that on stage you want
to go hey i know the suicide rate is
high here but
it's mutual i'm with you i hate it i
want to kill myself here too
this is a nightmare you can't because
even in the towns
you still can't [ __ ] on there it's still
where they live they still have like
that's the thing you got to respect is
like even if they don't like their
hometown they're still hometown pride
yes yes yes exactly it's like uh
your your mom or dad can beat the [ __ ]
out of you but they're still your mom
and dad so if i'm like
your dad's a [ __ ] idiot they're like
hey he beats the [ __ ] out of me but he's
still my dad [ __ ] you
exactly and like you can say your dad is
shitty he's your dad but if some
stranger goes you have a shitty dad
you're like [ __ ] you my dad's not shitty
he'll fight you
that's us coming in saying [ __ ] syracuse
yeah you can't
say it you gotta go with the flow and
they're like oh look at these city guys
coming up here thinking they're hot [ __ ]
you're like no no no we have low
self-esteem as well it just it just
sucks here
it's cold i should i should tell you
what happened to me last night i gave
you
oh yeah the bear details but uh
hospital quick trip i'm fine uh
yeah dude [ __ ] a few stitches in my
shin
it's completely my fault yeah i was
looking at
here's here's how much i'm falling apart
i
i see a guy who he's like a specialist
for your
uh neck and shoulders uh he's a massage
therapist and he's really good and like
i
leave there and i'm like all right i'm
in so much pain in my back
i'm in physical therapy for my neck
right now so i'm leaving i'm walking
home i'm looking at my phone
spacing out walking quickly looking at
my phone like a [ __ ] idiot
yeah how right into a right into a metal
bench
oh yeah one of the things
like like a like a bus stop ben what
kind of bench are we talking here
no it's like a metal you know those like
sharp ones are just kind of hanging out
the sides are kind of sharp a little bit
oh yeah
so i just walked into one of those and a
guy watched me do it and felt
like rightfully zero sympathy for me
because it's like he's like i saw you
looking at your phone
he's like i know you and i'm like in my
head i'm like extra mad because i'm like
[ __ ] i deserve this
in my head i'm thinking about like
they're gonna [ __ ] turn the
mach the machines are gonna turn against
us and like they don't have to
they already have us
i'm like [ __ ] the blood is just shooting
down my leg
and i'm just i'm like kind of hobbling
there's an urgent care across the street
i kind of hobble into the urgent care
like can i see someone and the lady goes
we're closed ah jeez i said well the
lights are off
yeah [ __ ]
[Laughter]
crazy it's a hospital or it's a care
place we're closed
we can't have you we don't have anyone
here and i was like then why are you
guys just hanging out
like don't you just leave so i'm like
pissed i walk out i hobble out
i'm i'm freaking out uh i sound like
mcdonald's breakfast by the way
yeah sorry until after 11 weeks but you
got all the [ __ ] patties and the eggs
yeah it was after 11. that's brutal
sorry to cut you off
no please this is what this is so i'm
hobbling down the street
a guy sees me bent over with blood kind
of just shooting down my leg so he goes
are you okay go i'm just i'm hurting a
little bit yeah
and he great guy [ __ ] new yorkers man
he goes let me help you get a cab
go to the hospital i said all right get
in the cab
i'm in the hospital or in the in the cab
going to the hospital and
uh immediately the driver i just say can
you take me to hospital he starts
driving
the wrong way i'm like hey man there's
one like 10 blocks from here just go to
that one
and yeah okay and i'm like i'm glad i'm
from here
and then he goes hospital like what
happened i said oh my leg's pretty
bloody and he goes
are you getting blood in my car i'm like
nah it's in my pants and he goes okay
good
[Laughter]
jesus christ the classic new york thing
and then i could tell he felt bad he
goes are you okay and i was like yeah
i'm all right i'm all right
so i walk in i go through
uh they have you know the they got the
little it's like an airport now you got
to go through uh
right sector to get in the hospital uh
so i go in
is it covered crazy is it just buzzing
it wasn't horrible there's a few people
in there i mean this is it was it's a
mess i mean it's not a good place to
work so i walk
down and i'm sitting there waiting for
them to call me and i'm like bleeding a
lot so at a certain point i'm just like
uh hey i just want to make sure this
isn't serious can someone just see me
and if it's not serious i'll happily
wait in another room whatever and
and the woman goes all right let's like
what is it like
like they're i'm like is this the
[ __ ] dmv or the hospital
like what's going on right yeah she's
she's giving me [ __ ] and i just said
here's my name i'm going through my name
what's your name i go samurail and she
goes
all right is that the name on your
driver's license and i said it's samuel
on the driver's license and she goes
then why didn't you tell me that
why you give me nicknames and i was like
i'm bleeding a lot i'm not [ __ ] with
you like what do you think i'm doing oh
that's hilarious she's hitting me with
the sass and i was like yeah
lady [ __ ] so finally i just go this is
my info please just let me know when i'm
ready i'm bleeding a lot she looks at me
like
like doesn't give a [ __ ] at all and i'm
like all right i mean like i get that
i get that you've seen worse today don't
get me wrong
but still it's ironic that they call
these places a new york
care because nobody cares that's the
last thing you know
like we care about you you don't give a
[ __ ] about me so don't call it care it's
called
urgent care come on help me out more
like urgent apathy am i right all right
so i uh i'm just sitting there waiting
some guy walks in this old guy walks in
he's high as [ __ ] like off his ass high
reeking of weed and it's like honestly
the only thing that's making me smile a
little bit is this old man as high as
[ __ ]
so he's there a woman and her husband
walk in and she goes
please my husband's having a horrible
allergic reaction he needs to be seen
and the high guy goes come right in come
right in no he's got to go through
security still
the high guy goes no no you're he's like
going at the guy and i'm just like ah
this is a [ __ ] [ __ ] show so i'm just
finally they see me
i'm in there for a couple hours but they
stitch me up i'm fine
you know yeah god damn unbelievable
so and also i told the guy i'm like look
i get this isn't the top of your list
you've seen some real [ __ ]
it's a saturday in the er you've seen
worship
and something that needs four stitches
but like it is on the shin it does hurt
a little bit and he's like no i
i and i said did i overreact coming here
said no you absolutely should have come
in i was like all right
sometimes for a couple things the shin i
was a skateboarder
i [ __ ] my shins up if you put your
hand down my shin it feels like it's
like
rigid it's like uh was serrated yeah
so the shin is the worst pain and
secondly it sucks you got no story
you know what happened did you did you
kick open a manhole and help a lady or
whatever it is
uh did you get it by a car yeah the
phone
that sucks well i mean the no story is
kind of the story though at the end of
the day that's
true i mean the no story the the fact
that i'm [ __ ] incompetent
is is i guess the story unfortunately
now but uh
yeah it's a bummer like uh maybe you can
use it like uh
oh i was looking at my phone i was
plugging my new special
you know or something like that it's
just somehow you can get something out
of it
yeah uh yeah it's [ __ ] annoying i'm
annoyed that this
is how it happened but then you're just
like
thank god it wasn't worse you know yeah
there's something there i'll crack it
i'll get a i'll get some bit out of it
the id
definitely the funny thing is like new
yorkers are just such [ __ ] trash
unless it's an emergency
they're just really like garbage and
then like they're like oh [ __ ] this
guy's hobbling i'll help
but like any other time any other time
like go [ __ ] yourself i mean
yeah exactly we'll crack it at some
point at least you know in new york
you got the high guy you got the cabbie
guy who's funny you got the sassy nurse
this
it's like a little adventure every
everywhere you go so you get that
fun part of like it's entertaining at
least every new york it does feel like
you get like a taste of after hours at
scorsese movie
right exactly yeah there's all these
characters somebody had to cast
that sassy nurse it feels like you know
but it's just real
do you ever go to the when's the last
time you went to the er i'm a big avoid
the hospital guy like two things i never
do is call the cops and go to the
hospital i just i don't want to involve
them
the the like the civil service workers
scare me for some reason because it's
just too
anytime that's going down it's never
good so like i like to just avoid all
that [ __ ] but
i tore my sack open in college i had to
go to the er
and it was a nightmare what was his name
it was rough i i got into a fist fight
in a at a party in college in the
backyard oh my god
i was losing the fight so i jumped over
the fence in
a moment of cowardice and the fence had
like spikes up top it was a black
wrought iron fence
and i caught the the sack on the on the
leg over like on the straddle
and i uh i tore the sack and i had to
run i remember i was dangling by my
jeans
and they all were laughing i was on the
other side of the fence hanging there
and they're like look at this [ __ ]
idiot
you know oh dude gave way i ran home
went to the hospital
uh but they had to sew it up in front of
me it was a nightmare oh my god
yeah you got your sack ripped up
by being a coward that sucks yeah i mean
in my defense i i i hung in the fight
for as long as i could but i was losing
so bad
and i had to get out of there but uh man
it was like out of a movie i got a big
needle in my sack
the guy's asking about the the he's like
you like the tigers what are you a
saints guy and he's like stitching me up
and then oh lsu
lsu yeah yeah the hot nurse comes in and
she's putting neosporin on my
on my freshly sewn up scrotum
oh and i got the acorn dick it's cold in
there
yeah it's a nightmare oh [ __ ]
had to wear a jock strap for two months
it's it's hilarious that we get like
because i think that's a common male
thing is that if you get like shrinkage
before a testicular exam or something
you're in your head
like like the [ __ ] like the doctor's
going to the next room like we got a
tiny one in [ __ ] room five
like i don't know why that's so in but
like every guy if we're not at our
[ __ ] best
penis-wise i don't know why we do that
in their defense though wouldn't i would
do that i'd be like jeez we got a real
uh frightened turtle in in 4b
are they leaving the other rooms like
you should [ __ ] you should try to get
a second look i mean this is [ __ ]
special
like we should miss diagnosis just to
get a second peak you know
exactly exactly that's that's what i
would do so i i assume they're doing
that and she was like
25 she was young and she's probably
jesus guys poor thing can't uh
he can't pleasure a woman with that
thing
it is funny too that like the idea that
like what what do you say when a guy
will fight you say he's got balls
oh interesting you literally
you literally didn't have balls after
you ran away to the balls
your balls got shredded yeah they got
shredded you're right and
here's the craziest part i went to bed i
passed out at home
woke up went to work because you know
you're still drunk you just get up and
you go
and i was i was a waiter at the time i
was like god my balls are stinging my
sack
and i went to the bathroom and it was
torn open i didn't even know it
because i blacked out and i saw a ball
that's [ __ ] gross it was well it
looks like a peach pit
it was wild i panicked and i just ran to
the hospital
crazy college
you went to uh tulane you probably had
some wild drunk nights
yeah absolutely i mean that roofie story
is from uh
from the deke house oh i know it on
broadway
sure yeah yeah a lot of uh a lot of
drunken nights there
definitely uh i mean new orleans is a
wild
wild city that is it really is
it's like a dangerous time i mean i do
remember
uh [ __ ] i mean you must have seen so
many how many mardi gras have you been
there for like almost
like when how when's the first mardi
gras you went to
oh i mean i was a baby there's pictures
of me on my dad's shoulders
you know at like four you know catching
beads and [ __ ] i remember seeing
like boobs you know in the french
quarter at mardi gras all that [ __ ]
so you throw beads and another
four-year-old you're like show me your
tits
yeah exactly uh just a flat little girl
but yeah show me your diaper but yeah it
was uh it was just it's just part of the
culture it's like um
you know it's like a little italy it's
like i always say new orleans
in the us is like it's like what
montreal is to canada
oh yeah it's got that like kind of
french influence but then also
uh it's just there's nothing like it
right in america it's so
it's it could be like not part of our
country and be like oh yeah that makes
sense
you know yeah yeah if montreal was
molested young
because obviously we got so many more
you know issues and uh devices here
we've got the prostitution and the strip
clubs and the corrupt politicians i mean
it's like
it is a classic like i want to know more
about yours there's
no politician there like you just
picture every governor
out of louisiana like ev every [ __ ]
mayor new orleans should be playing like
at some shady poker game at four in the
morning yeah
yeah biting a cigar whiskey
but when katrina happened all these uh
like what do you call it televangelists
and like religious people like
that was god trying to teach you guys
you guys are so gross and dirty
it was god trying to wash you of your
sins and we're like ah shut up you
[ __ ] [ __ ]
the same oh dude televangelist like i
don't know how the [ __ ] they sleep at
night it's a it's such a
remember joel osteen was like the whole
thing like you need to love that
neighbor you got to take
care of people it was like the flood in
houston he was like get the [ __ ] out of
my church get out of here
yeah he's like we just did the carpets
get the [ __ ] out of here
[Laughter]
i know how who i don't even blame those
guys because they're obviously like just
grifters and
yeah [ __ ] like that but like these
people fall for that [ __ ] i guess
i guess everybody just needs a needs
something to follow
it's also like you get to a point like
joel osteen where you've been rich too
long
that you're like yeah you can't be you
gotta like get weeded out at a certain
point you if you play in arenas
as a televangelist you're [ __ ] you're
horrible you're full of [ __ ]
yeah i know i know you've made so many
you've lied to so many people that
you've bought a [ __ ]
dome you know like it's gotta be that's
gonna be the cap you're done
if you're all about god and you're
driving better than a mercedes
some shit's shady going on right if
you're all about like [ __ ] material
possessions i'm like all right but let
me see your home
i want to see what your home looks like
i want to see you practice where you
preach a little bit
you know yes exactly exactly i i don't
get how anyone could fall for them and
then you ever watch those guys like
sometimes i'll like yeah i'm flipping
through i'll leave it on and it's just
horrifying it if i saw that i think i
followed one of them at the syracuse
funny bone
but they're just oh god i do all these
big act outs and
ah it's so creepy [ __ ] it can never
follow an act out
it's always [ __ ] that's very central
so
uh tell me some [ __ ] like what's what's
something you're
enjoying in this like is there any shows
any like
any just life things any movies what are
you doing man well
i i want to try to because everybody
recommends the same things you know you
got to watch this you gotta see this you
gotta see this i try to go outside the
box by the way
i'm i'm six episodes into the crown
loving it
really yeah me and the lady watch it we
love it
it's a good with the girlfriend show
because it's like it's got the historial
historical factor
it's i like shows you're like did this
[ __ ] really happen and send you to
google too
yes yeah i mean how great is the uh the
slimy
brother guy who's like got a ab what is
it abduct
abdicated abdicated yes
oh my god [ __ ] not he's great yeah
so and apparently obviously we just like
you said we googled
he wrote a lot of those letters those
are real yeah
crazy scumbag dude scumbag
and he's such a slithering slimy weasel
and so fun and just the power dynamics
of the the optics and all that it all
it all registers today so funny to be
like
like look what was i gonna do burn a
bridge with hitler and you're like yes
that's what you do you kind of burn the
hitler bridge
exactly but he's kim jong-il now you're
like i don't know if i want to piss off
this flathead
but yeah it's funny at all we're all
humans it just keeps repeating like just
human nature
speaking of kim jong-il best remember
kim jong-un geraldo had a bit where he
goes
how short do you have to be to have a
napoleon complex in north korea
ah what a [ __ ] line [ __ ] one liner
where you're just
like bam damn and that's a smart
foreign policy joke that everybody can
get totally
uh so so you're the crown is what you're
were you into right now no no crowd
too many people already like the crown
people know about the crown so i thought
i went
a little more obscure salaccus are our
mutual pal
director of your new special and uh you
know
photographer friend extraordinaire he's
photographed
everyone from rihanna to noah bomback to
anyone you could think of
just an amazing eye yeah he's a beast
yeah he's got everybody
uh he recommended we we we share a
i don't know i wanna i don't wanna get
too uh candid here but we share
he got me hooked up on a fake cable
service oh i've heard about this
not fake but you told me yeah yeah yeah
it i love it it's great it's
it's janky it's shady it's weird it's
under the table but i love it it feels
like the 90s again where i got you
remember when the kids had the box
yeah cause i like that limewire yeah
yeah it's all that
remember like that's what we'll tell our
grandkids like you get the stream porn
we have to download the whole thing
before we watch it
i used to print porn i had to wait for
it to go
oh dude i ran a porn magazine in sixth
grade
what yeah my friend and i ran we called
it play amigo his dad is a color printer
so we're like why don't we just print
out
why don't we just print out a nude po
it's like it was just like baywatch like
oh like donna dierko's naked let's use
that one
oh yeah and it would just be like play
amigo and
uh it would just be a few pages and i we
had i remember i had a
great teacher he passed away not too
long ago
mr jones old gay man was so such a good
guy stupid teacher and i remember he
found he busted me with play amigo
i was trying to sell it in the bathroom
and he caught me and uh
and he goes i'll just tell the principal
they were sears catalogs if anyone asks
ah that's great great guy
so you you would pre like bind them and
print them and sell them staple them
bind is
it's very bare bones here true but i
feel like you lose you're losing more
money on on printer ink
it was it was his dad's printer so that
was our that was our scheme
that's on you pops
dad's like i'm just trying to print out
my [ __ ] flight itinerary here
all the uh all the pink is gone from all
the gash
he's like yeah i was trying to get a
flight to dallas why are yasmine
bleached
hits in my printer yeah yeah i know
delta the delta guy's like jesus
uh all right so documentary
from the 80s early 80s unbelievable
never heard of it it's called streetwise
wow
some guy was a photographer and he was
shooting photos for a magazine like
newsweek
of all these homeless teenagers in
seattle
and it was so he got to know them it was
so like interesting and enthralling that
he made it into a documentary and like
came back and shot him with
you know video cameras and it's so cool
it's so good you got to watch it
i'll put it in request street wise is it
is it on a service or do i have to get
hooked up to your legal setup that you
guys have
you might have to go illegal but i bet
itunes would have it if you have any of
that or maybe amazon
streetwise but it is i mean it's like
raw
it's like the the movie kids but real
okay interesting real [ __ ] i mean the
the the girl is a prostitute she's 14
she's got all these stds she keeps
having abortions the one kid's in like a
street gang he's like getting cut up
with knives i mean it's [ __ ]
these are like white seattle pacific
northwest kids it's [ __ ] fascinating
damn it's great and and it's so 80s too
the way they're dressed the cars there's
no phones there's no internet obviously
and it's
it's it's pretty great i love a good
dock you know
you know it's an 80s classic dock that
i'd never seen until
recently was have you heard of the thin
blue line i have it's won all these
awards everybody
raves about it i i'm pissed that i can't
remember the guy's name who made it oh
uh
god he's super famous
uh the thin blue it's so good man uh
yeah that's like a staple yeah for aero
morris
that's it yeah it's so good i mean dude
crazy good crazy it takes a minute
because it takes a minute because some
older some older docs man
like we realize especially even with
autumn you even should watch an older
movie now and you're like oh this is
like
embarrassing what's been done to my
attention span
ah dude you try to watch like taxi
driver now and you're like oh he [ __ ]
took his time that's what he's doing
right right and it's okay it's like
fleshed out
and pretty and totally but but we don't
give a [ __ ] we just
get to it i'm saying we're the problem
oh yeah
i agree i'm not blaming scorsese movies
were
like an experience yes 70 so you'd go to
the theater and you'd be like oh this is
what
i want to experience this and now we're
like all right [ __ ] get to it
yeah it's a bummer that that's what it
is but that is what it is now
and and everything is going to be that
and if we want to sell a show we have to
adapt too so
that's just i mean even like the intro
to like a sitcom
like was was three minutes or two
minutes back in the day now it's just
like
bum bum we're in you know boom or you
have the option to skip one of the other
yeah you know like
exactly i tried so when i found myself
skipping like the 30 rock intro i was
like all right dude give it it's
10 seconds 10 seconds
her husband wrote that by the way so
good dude yeah you watch the scenes in
that movie and you're
in that show and you're just like oh
every scene musically is
insane it's so it adds to how funny it
is so funny the joke it's a joke a
second
uh i was watching it the other day and
uh there's a black gay guy
and tina fey is getting in trouble for
like not being pc enough
she's like well you know you gotta ask
twofer and the guy's like what
twofer and she's like oh he's a twofer
he's black and gay that's two for one
and they were like you're out i remember
yeah it's like it's crazy you see what
was on
nbc just like what 12 years ago whatever
and you're like oh [ __ ] times
they're moving the goal post then that's
all yeah
i know and i get hope because i'm like
tina fey is clearly
a super smart good you know
decent human being and she's making
these crazy offensive jokes so you're
like oh okay
i'm not evil where do you rank that show
like is that in your top five comedies
ever for
for sitcoms or no it's up there i mean
the problem is every now and then you'll
watch one you're like this whole eps is
kind of a dud
well but that's like a later season i
think i think early seasons are pretty
what what's your top five not just top
five
straight up comedies i mean you know i
love seinfeld i love
i love i think frasier is underrated
it's great
uh kelsey grammer is a [ __ ] beast too
it's killer
i saw david hyde pierce in the subway
like a year ago and i was like [ __ ]
david hyde pierce it made me happy
just just a little hat looking [ __ ]
just like
you know like yeah that's that's killer
a lot of people like cheers and raymond
i wasn't too into him
cheers is great raymond i like i like
all the actors
[ __ ] but like uh two family too much
heart
it's not even the heart it's the other
thing of like with like the with a
husband is just so [ __ ] whipped that
i'm just like this just looks miserable
like she's just
it just it just felt like she's always
mad at him like
right right like it's like that movie
you ever see that movie the breakup with
vince vaughn and uh yeah
you know i'm like yeah this is realistic
to a point where like that's why it's
like i'm almost not enjoying this
it's not like it's like kind of half
escapist and half like
like they nailed what a breakup feels
like and i was like that's kind of why
i'm like
this is tough to watch as a yeah it was
built as a comedy i was expecting a
comedy
and then you go and you're like well
this isn't a bad movie but it's just
like [ __ ]
a downer it's it's two peoples really
who like clearly love each other's
relationship
just falling apart right right it's
pretty heavy
uh what's another good what's another
good comedy i mean obviously you got
south park and
family guy that's all i love curb
yeah uh so yeah there's so many so many
then there's arrested development and
there's
parks and rec is okay yeah well
it's too many why what are you too many
no i don't i mean simpsons is
mine for sure you know you know a lot of
them like top three
i think like top seasons like one
through eight or like
all i'd even go like nine or ten maybe
or like
one through eight or it's the best thing
i've ever seen probably but most people
won't go that late
eight i think they'll go eight all right
all right i think eight is a great
season i
i just i love simpsons i love uh
i mean larry sanders is in the oh
another great one
30 rock kills me for sure yeah british
and american office i like a lot
both oh yeah love bowed love love the
british one yeah
i loved your vase man i love extras
cracks me up too
i just i think gervais is awesome yeah
he'll uh
he follows me on twitter oh [ __ ] yeah i
don't know how he got my [ __ ] or
whatever but he
he'll like stuff every now and then it
means the world to me
that's a that's a biggie though that's
cool yeah he loves jokes and
we just tweet jokes and i think he digs
that
yeah man jokes i mean speaking of any
any
anything you're working on anything oh
wait you didn't say you're you're you're
what are you recommending oh food show
okay
um okay i watched an old movie i'd never
seen that i really liked we're throwing
out obscure [ __ ] so why not
i love old noir like my favorite movies
are probably
just for like language i go like 40s
50s film noir yeah uh so every once in a
while someone will throw one at me that
i haven't seen and uh
i watched and it's i think it's one of
kubrick's first movies if not
one of his like earliest was is this
movie called the killers
hmm it's a great it's a great heist
movie the dialogue is so
[ __ ] funny like really it's just a
killer script
and uh sterling hayden from dr
strangelove is
one of the leads in it uh
it's great there's all right there's a
guy who's like [ __ ] whipped out of the
gate and he's talking about doing the
heist and his wife is cheating on him
she wants nothing to do with him and
she's
he goes so i saw this woman she was
about 35 he's going a long time with
this story she goes she was 35 when the
story started how old is she now like
lines like that really
oh i love it i love it there's also a
lot where she says to
this woman she's spying on their heist
and he goes baby you better you better
tell me what i want to hear i'm going to
smash your face in a hamburger meat
you're just like this really was the 50s
holy [ __ ]
wow man i've never heard of this oh
i mean strange love has got some great
lines in it and so [ __ ] funny
i'll check it out i've never i can't
believe i'm embarrassed i've never heard
that and he's a bronx guy
who kubrick is yeah yeah oh i didn't
know that
yeah yeah i like i'm obsessed with
anyone from new york because i just
picture their their whole upbringing
yeah kubrick's great man oh yeah strange
love is is a great comedy
yeah certain parts don't hold up but
then other parts you're like
[ __ ] this is um i mean i know people
probably trash me for even
saying certain parts don't hold up but
like yeah i i love
so many i mean [ __ ] what's his name
the the main guy who's doing multiple
roles in that again i'm just close up
what's his [ __ ] name peter uh
sellers [ __ ] yeah i'm a step slow
tonight i know these people's names i've
had a couple drinks but uh
same same uh yeah dude i love him tell
me about you working on
killers i i gotta remember that i do i
love noir i love like
yeah one of my other favorites is uh
i mean i like this one have you ever
seen out of the past or the robert
mitchum
no that's like that might be like my
number one film noir it's funny really
it's perfect mitchell mitchum just
[ __ ] ruled that was like a real
man that was a real manly dude he they
also did a remake of farewell my lovely
where he plays the lead
i just anytime mitch him i'm just like
oh that's a [ __ ]
that's a real dude he's awesome all
right all right
i'm i mean out of the pad it's just
classic noir a guy who tried to walk
away from the game and it catches up
with him kirk young kirk douglas is in
it he's great it's awesome
all right see killer dialogue this this
this [ __ ]
ripped uh illegal channel i have had
will have all that
i know i've been to salahusa's place and
we've watched
we've watched it on and he's just like
he's like why don't we see what pacino
movies are on right now
it's like dog day afternoon uh scarface
the godfather i'm like jesus christ
it's got every you could watch a like a
[ __ ] jerry lewis roast from
1954 and then you can watch you know
uh the killers well killers
killers a lot of fun you know you'll
you'll get a kick for sure i mean those
old
noirs are just like they're just fun
what was the other one you said the
mitchum out of the pass is out of the
past that's one of my all-timers for
for like a perfect noir so good
all right now i got some bits here but
obviously we can't get up as much and uh
i should be writing more so
these are so raw i mean oh i got one i
got big
i got only trash so okay great come at
me dude maybe we should do a couple just
to
i might have to redeem myself some are
so bad oh dude i got nothing
all right all right uh here we go i'll
try to do some because i
i throw most of them at you so i'll try
to do something you haven't seen or
heard yet
uh so i want to do a bit about how the
robe
and it's perfect because you're wearing
one the robe has so much
range more than any other clothing item
because it can be a supreme court judge
a boxer uh on a sale asylum victim
a divorced dad getting the paper uh
uh like a pope you know the rope it can
go from
pope to guy or guy going to an orgy
i love that you're either a deadbeat or
on the supreme court
exactly exactly the robe is amazing
and uh i feel like you could just go so
many way go somebody wait like hefner
wore a robe but but so does tony soprano
when he's getting the
the paper yes it's got it's got so much
range
yeah it's either like i worked my entire
life
to hold a gavel yeah or i'm a bum
and i don't feel like getting dressed
like there's no
you're right there's like no like the
pope like that guy it's a different type
of robe sure you know because it comes
with a [ __ ] hat
you can't just wear the robe and not the
hat right right
even like like the grand wizard is kind
of wearing a robe
that's true so you got the supreme court
the most justice guy ever
versus the [ __ ] most evil guy ever
yeah it's interesting and it's like i
guess it depends on if it comes with
other accessories
like if it comes with a gavel supreme
court right
or judge or whatever right if you're if
you're uh
if you're the pope it comes with a hat
yeah if you're a kkk it comes with the
hood
if your deadbeat comes with a remote hey
maybe that's great it's like not it or
maybe something like that i don't know
i like that i like that that's that's a
good it's a good way to go with it and
also
to me the judge is the most fun robe guy
because you call him your honor
he's like this he's like this
prestigious guy
we have to like kiss his ass your honor
yes sir no sir
uh you will address the court blah blah
blah you know he's in control
and you have to wear a suit in court you
got to wear a suit and you got to blow
the guy
who figured out how to wear a robe and
you know he's bigger than you and better
than you
and you're in the suit and he's in a
robe at work that's interesting yeah
like a guy in a robe
telling a guy in a suit silence yeah
order in the court
that's your honor yeah that's
interesting yeah like
although i guess that would happen with
tony someone someone else shows up with
in
in this in a suit he's there in his robe
like shut the [ __ ] up
right you're right the robe is kind of
maybe the angles at the robe is
a symbol of power because you're either
you're
either in charge or you're you have so
little going on
that you've got power right right like
your your divorced wife comes over like
you got you're in a robe
it's [ __ ] noon you're not you're not
having a job and he's like i know but
i get to wear whatever i want because
i'm out of your [ __ ] life
that's that's why i wear it that's it
even if you're in a hotel and you're
wearing a robe
you're not answering anyone you're doing
right you're jacking off
things are going pretty well there it is
i think about the power the robe is all
about power that's great even if you're
unemployed that was your choice no one's
telling you what to do you're in a robe
yeah i don't feel like a lot of guys in
robes are like actively searching for a
job
no no exactly i don't think i don't
think anyone in a robe is like [ __ ] let
me get my
my resume in order here no yeah i think
you're all right
right right like my dad wore a robe
around the house
by the way no underwear it was
terrifying but
if he was in the robe he wasn't helping
us like i was like dad i need to ride to
billy's house and he's like
i'm in a robe and you're like oh yeah
okay
i mean it was powerful i'm in a robe is
clean go [ __ ] yourself
yeah yeah exactly and if you oh how
about the flasher
just whoo you know that's power
they can clear a whole subway car with
that although
if you're a flasher you quickly lose the
power
right because your accessory quickly
becomes handcuffs
yeah exactly i don't know where to go
with that but that but yeah but the
flasher like
in the moment yeah i think in the moment
the robe is power
that's gold power baby it's all about
power supreme court
deadbeat dead there's something there
for sure i think that's worth
[ __ ] it's hard to not get to try bits
enough man i'm missing i know
we're junkies we're like [ __ ] heroin
addicts who are like
guess i'm clean now and i should feel
good but i just missed the heroine
well that's what zoom is zoom is the
methadone it gives you just that little
bit of hit
that keeps you going i'm down to you i'm
gonna do people [ __ ] on zoom shows and
like i don't like them but i'll take
them over like a drive-through show i'd
rather like at least yeah
laugh i agree and you'll have to leave
and man those drive-through shows the
honking the lights
it's it's not helping me i mean if you
do really well you get the wipers
all right what do you got i had this
idea so like on set you know sesame
street is always like ahead of their
time
kind of and like they try to teach kids
like you look at it even like in the 80s
they're like doing [ __ ] like well this
is a drag queen like they're very
right trying to show kids to be
respectful of people who are different
clearly a very progressive stance always
so uh
like they had one recently where they're
like you know can you imagine how
difficult it would be to leave your home
and you know the other puppet is like
well i would never want to leave sesame
street but it's just about immigrants
and how hard it is for them to leave
their home
so they're like we should be nicer to
people coming to our country because
leaving home is hard but it's
it's just about immigrants so i wish
they would take on other
you know issues like like grover when
does a human life
really start and you're like well you
like that your mommy carried her
pregnancy to term don't you
you liked that she didn't throw you in
an oscar that grouch's little garbage
can and get rid of you
or something like right right like how
far are we gonna go
how uncomfortable are we gonna make it
for these kids trying to be progressive
i'd also love if they just like went the
other way where they're like sesame
street's a pretty safe neighborhood
isn't it
like aren't you glad that like violent
puppets don't move here
right right yeah ones that weren't born
here i don't know something like that
well there's also something with the the
beginning part like it's hard for some
people to leave the house and
it's i thought you were going to talk
about depression oh i love the idea of a
depressed puppet like
big bird's like well i should i guess we
had snuffleupagus but that's dave
chappelle's bit
but yeah yeah i just love the idea of
big bird like
yeah i don't want to be here all the
time you know but i suck it up and i get
it together i took a shot of brandy and
i leave the house
but that's great it's also like uh it's
funny because kids shows try to explain
really complex and nuanced things to
kids and it's kind of admirable but also
it's [ __ ] weird
yeah like mr rogers would talk about
like well i feel sad sometimes
right oh you talking also like it is
funny that you're trying to just reach
like depressed
like what kid is like super depressed
[Laughter]
like you either you either don't know
you're depressed yet because you're too
young to like put that together or it's
also [ __ ] up if you don't know when
you're watching and you're just like
[ __ ] i'm i'm depressed right right yeah
maybe a kid shouldn't know about
depression because then he can know he
has it
also my mom i used to watch uh mr rogers
i loved it as a kid
and they had a big episode about death
like you know some kid's mom dies or
whatever so they have an episode about
it which is great
and thoughtful and all that for that kid
but my mom was alive
this show sucks i don't care about this
app this is doing nothing for me
oh you ever just like re-watching the
show and you're like skip like
[ __ ] like i was just re-watching
sopranos i'm like gotta skip the rape
episode i don't want to see this [ __ ]
like
like mr rogers like i wasn't ready we're
not all ready for this [ __ ]
exactly i i know it's uh progressive
we're moving forward and it's helpful
but like
not everybody's going through it so what
about those kids now you're just forcing
sadness onto me instead of helping me
go through it with therapeutics good
you're good
uh oh [ __ ] i had another oh oh this
could be a funny angle on that too with
like the
the immigrant thing yeah what if there's
the one kid
who's dead is pumping the kid full of
[ __ ] so now the kid's fighting back
what do you mean like like if if like
let's say
big bird is like uh yeah you know if
some people want to move here and
it's hard for them we should treat them
fairly and respectfully and the kids
like
yeah but they're taking our jobs and my
uncle used to work at the mill and then
some mexican guy came in and big bird's
like
whoa whoa whoa whoa you know this is not
how i thought this was gonna go you know
and
or they're talking about trans and he's
like gender is a construct billy you
gotta remember that he's like but i
thought the future was female
like you know it's just some
five-year-old kid pushing back
uh just genuinely yeah i also love the
idea if they just like
as big birds talking him out of it some
like some like spanish
big bird with a mustache like it's like
it's like ah
almost it's it's uh it's me right i
worry it's me yeah yeah i'm out of here
my spanish
he's everything he said he takes it all
back he's like [ __ ] this [ __ ] i've been
working here
this [ __ ] piece of [ __ ] come in here
all of a sudden his voice changes
what is he he's making less than me
aren't is he yeah he's
taking a pay pay cut that's what it is
oh that's funny
what else you got uh i got a bunch um
how about this so
i'll watch ufc or boxing and my
girlfriend is like man i don't know how
you watch this [ __ ] like
look what these people are doing to each
other it's so evil and like
inhumane the pain and the the the you
know the physical pain they're putting
on people and i'm like yeah but you
watch
90 day fiance and all this and i'm like
bachelorette like that's a different
kind of pain so
we both came to the conclusion like well
they signed up they signed up they know
what they're getting into
but it's funny how like men i'll watch
and i'm doing a men and women here thing
but
men will watch physical pain but women
will never watch physical pain but
they'll watch
emotional pain to me this guy
moving to america from nepal
or tibet or whatever the [ __ ] and you
know trying to [ __ ] some fat old white
lady
and he's screwing her over i'm like this
is way
i get this is way darker i love it yeah
way darker
way darker it's also funny how women are
like like
you watch the wire it's so upsetting i'm
like you watch handmaid's tale like what
like what are you exactly they're both
upsetting we're dealing with different
things here
but i totally get what you're saying how
like emotional manipulation
to me is darker than
yes then like a knockout punch sucks but
guess what that guy trained his whole
life he can take a punch
you know exactly and he'll wake up woman
this woman may never bounce back
exactly exactly this is way darker way
more harsh
and she couldn't see that she was like
well you know you live you learn
whatever and they're by the way there's
way more crying
on these reality shows than there is in
the octagon you live and you learn
she [ __ ] told her mom about this guy
yes
like she thought this was gonna work out
she has a a tiny daughter who's like six
going is
is ricardo my new dad you know and
ricardo left with the beamer
it's rough 90 day fiance bums me out man
oh crushes me and he sees like i get why
people love it but it bums
yeah it's like [ __ ] candy it's like
so easily
digestible but this poor guy is like
some dopey
dweeby guy is getting rooked by some
chick in uh
russia who's who's just like scamming
him from all this money he's like she
loves me she loves me i'm like
oh god it's it's like it works it's like
this nigerian email scam or a person
every episode
and you're like this is uplifting for
you right right yeah and she's like but
look
look at these two they're wrestling and
he's bending his arm back i'm like
that arm doesn't have feelings like
it'll go back in the socket
and everything's fine this is way way
meaner
yeah it's like weird i'm not a huge ufc
guy or mma guy and i think it's mostly
because i just don't know a ton about it
i got if
i remember i watched a fight with lewis
and dave once and i got into it because
they both know so much about it that i
was kind of like oh this is cool i mean
all i need is someone to like show me
the way right
right i'm just sewing a basketball that
it consumes me
i'm so obsessed with that and i love
baseball i love
you know a lot of sports but like if i
had someone like show me
ufc i'd be all in yeah i think because i
was the same was like it's so barbaric
and so violent but i don't even think
that i just don't know enough about it
to appreciate it on the level that most
people do i think
uh-huh yeah because once you get into it
it's very cool and like the training
goes into it and like
it's very methodical and calculated
totally more so than just
i respect it a ton i wish i knew more
and i just
right so if like if someone was like
come to my place and watch with me i'd
be like 100
please just explain certain things to me
because i don't want to watch like a
[ __ ] or be like right
okay like uh it's almost like if you go
to the museum
and i'm like all right well can i have a
can i have a guide some background
i just i just want to know about the
thing yeah
and also i become more attached to them
as people like i like to know about the
yes watching like that's why i love the
nba i feel like i know about the drama
and i know about the athletes and i know
like
you know i know what's at stake and
right yeah so
i feel like i'm just a person like if i
watch with dave and lewis again i'd be
into it you know yeah
yeah it's pretty fast and i what i love
about ufc and boxing is like that
how the [ __ ] did this guy from
russia and this guy from ireland and
this guy from san jose
get into the same thing and now they're
competing like they all had this crazy
backstory
and you know partnership and struggle i
love that [ __ ] but
can i say this making a
macro here i feel like our youtube
specials
not only like funny and all that but
they have a lot of
backstory that people can get they sink
their teeth into with like
the networks wouldn't pick them up these
are [ __ ] new york hustler guys who
are just trying to make it and
no one will buy their [ __ ] so they're
putting out on their own and i think
that adds to the appeal of it
yeah i got to promote my new one more
like that in the fact that
you know right when people wouldn't pick
it up and it's like we are
trying to put our [ __ ] into the world
like like
i think the underdog story people want
to you know
latch on to i think that that gets them
more kind of excited about
promoting something or into it
definitely no no doubt about it so
and you're right like if you're watching
like one of those [ __ ] cornball shows
like
the voice or anything if you like even
if you watch like shops like
there's always one guy who's like yeah i
got back from iraq and
my restaurant burned down and my wife
left me and now i'm all alone and then
there's another guy who's like yeah i
just like food and you're like yeah yeah
yeah
i'm rooting for the first guy right
right but sometimes that [ __ ] is so full
i did last comic standing you did
america's got talent i did it i did last
comic too
oh yeah i think it was in the year after
year yeah yeah and i was like i got
nothing i'm a piece of [ __ ] i'm a
janitor like you're a janitor oh my god
okay so you're a poor guy you're living
in a trailer
you beat your wife i'm like whoa whoa
i'm just trying to be funny here but
they want the story yeah well
when they hear janitor they think you're
a different person
i remember i did uh agt and they were
like asking questions about me and they
were like oh you're in a long-distance
relationship i said yeah they're like
all right well like facetime your
girlfriend will make it funny i was like
i don't want to [ __ ]
no so they made me do it on one and i
just was like
you know what i miss honey your vagina i
was trying to make it funny
and they were getting so mad i'm like
well at least now i know they won't use
it
right good point good point they they
hated me on those shows when whenever
they would do like a
like a confession one-on-one they're
like do you think you can beat reggie
i'm like no
reggie's a hack he's gonna kill me the
the judges they don't like real comedy
and they're like what are you doing this
isn't
this is what we want they want you to be
like i want to win this [ __ ] thing
i'm the funniest guy out here you know
oh they i remember on agt they were like
how bad do you want this i was like well
if i win
i have to do a residency in vegas right
like yeah i was like i [ __ ] hate
vegas i'm not going yes you know
i would just give them whatever they
didn't want i was like just air my stand
up that's all i have yes
please please exactly i don't like
giving other people control
of my story of my life because they they
especially a [ __ ] show as cheesy as
america's got talent like
i mean god bless howie mandel he's a
sweet as hell guy but you know
like it is you're part of a machine
that is just not that your wellness
is not it's not at all on their thoughts
no uh so yeah that's that's one that i'm
just like
yeah i i'd like to tell my own story
right i hear what i just said my story
[ __ ] me
this is my story this is my time but you
know what i mean like you don't want you
don't want to give other people
you know creative control so to speak of
course
what else what else do you got all right
all right oh wait wait wait was that
your bed or was it
where i did a robe you did
i think it's your turn you did you did
sesame street
yeah all right let me try another one uh
i think like with the way things are
going and this could be a nothing bit
but
how long until we have racist rehab
do we have that yet i feel like yeah
we got we got a video of david
hasselhoff [ __ ] face and then he goes to
alcoholics anonymous whatever you got a
video of this heroin addict so he goes
to
drug rehab we got a video of mel gibson
saying
you know jewish slurs and the n-word and
all this like how long do we have a
racist rehab i think that's that's
coming
yeah where someone's like uh
you gotta watch interracial porn taped
open i will say i'm working on a show
with someone we have canceled anonymous
for it's not a show it's different it's
a different bit but it's like we have a
sponsor so i like i feel like it's hard
for me to give notes on this because
we have we have a guy where we voted in
sponsors for people that are cancelled
you know so it's like someone gets like
in the script was like
you know it's cancelled anonymous so
michael richards walks in late like ooh
i'm like a kramer walks in late to the
meeting so that was like
or like so i i it's like a hard one for
me to give notes
i'm like [ __ ] i feel like it's like not
my bit but it's like hard to
to riff on you know let me let me try
another one that one is that one's
yeah it's a good premise all right i
don't want to step on anything or make
you reveal you're not stepping on
anything i'm just okay
this is a hard one for me to to jump in
on how about this so you know how
kids like we're adults we're in our 30s
and so we know a little more [ __ ] than
kids so we can go hey kid you know don't
do that
listen to me i was there once blah blah
blah and my friend
is transitioning into a man yeah it's a
lady transitional man
and i i get to be like hey don't do this
[ __ ]
and you know she's kind of like what the
hell are you doing i'm like hey
i'm a man i know more than you about
being a man like i'm
i've lived it is that too is that too
much of a stretch
because we were kids now we're adults we
were boys now we're men
man there's something funny about like
do you think
people who transition go to men and be
like
is this good right is this
can i that's like we talk about
networking do we do they get me pick
your brain
on being like you pick you pick brains
on being on a job
a comic do you pick brains
on on on brains yeah
yeah like this is how i am now i'm about
to get this surgery like i'm a man
inside but i'm gonna be a man societally
you know to the world
uh is there any tips you can give me
yeah there's something interesting about
that about like like i'm changing
uh i'm transitioning
can is this the right it's funny also
that like
because it's stuff like are they they're
they're also going like to a place where
like are they born
into the wrong body right so
like it's like almost like being gay
where you're like you're born that way
right that's how
i assume it is okay yeah i don't know
but i assume you're born
i think so that way and probably with
trans
you're born that way i would think yeah
but how about you know hey i'm i'm a
friend why not ask me for some tips
you're coming on on this team uh
publicly
shouldn't you want to know some [ __ ]
yeah it's kind of like uh
i mean [ __ ] if if you moved to ohio
i wouldn't just move to ohio hey mark
how's ohio
exactly exactly i'm not saying you're
you're less of an ohioan
you know because you will be living here
in ohio but i've been in ohio for 20
years
i identify as an ohioan i might have
been born in new york but i think i'm
i think i'm a toledo type of guy there
you go so
my point is where's my uh where's my
friend asking me for advice who's more
of an expert on being a male than a male
i wonder if they but and this is me just
being like hoping i don't sound like a
[ __ ] idiot here but like i wonder if
they're like
but i i am a man right right that's what
i'm like i am a man i'm in a woman's
body but i am a man
yeah yeah but i could be like you will
be treated like this or you will be
thought of this way or perceived that
way
i don't know it was one of those ideas
to hit me in the shower i was like oh
that's interesting but i don't know if
there's actually
any meat there
depends which way they're switching yeah
yeah
um hmm
yeah i think trans bits are hard because
i also i'm like i always wonder like
i always wonder not in like i'm going to
offend somebody it's more like
is this right am i right is this yes i'm
almost like
am i wrong about this so like that's my
only thing with transits i'm always like
you know um i don't know that i don't
know that many trans people i know
a couple i don't know that many so it's
not like uh
a black guy or gay guy i'm like i can
ask this
right right yeah yeah yeah maybe it's a
it's it's a silly idea all right well
what do you got
let me see what i got
what do we have okay this is an angle i
have about like how women will get
offended sometimes if you assume
that like a doctor or a lawyer just
someone with a really good job
is a man you know like oh yeah if you're
just like
like what was what was her name you're
like uh actually it was a guy
all right i mean i mean actually i mean
what was his name actually was a woman
right that's what i mean
but they don't do that with bad [ __ ]
it's never like a [ __ ] murderer
and they're like uh oh what was his name
um
her name all right francine the
strangler
actually you know that's funny they
never do it for the bad [ __ ]
yeah well it's like well women want the
they want the accolades but they don't
want like when a woman does something
bad they're just like
that's not all like it was like all
women it's almost like women stand
together
until the going gets tough right right
right yeah exactly exactly yeah
that might be the whole bit by the way
that might be [ __ ] done i don't know
if there's any more there
that feels good i mean you don't want to
step on the billboard bit of like
you know feminist or cherry picking you
know
totally totally take equal pay but we
also want you to buy dinner but we'll
take
that's a great bet great big great bid
and i i promise half hour i think that's
an old yeah
that's an og bird bit oh gee and the
women are dying in the crowd which is
the ultimate sign of a great bid
but yeah that's great they never serial
killer yeah the serial killer
she you know she
yeah a woman can do anything a man can
do
all right a bunch of rapists
that's funny they never do it for the
bad it's always like astronaut you know
these
you know my friend's an astronaut oh
what's his name her name is sarah
but it's never like uh my friend's an
axe murderer
what's his name her name is you know i
thought you wanted a quality
yeah it's something there's something
it's it's enough to play with what else
you got you wanna do one more each and
then call it a day
let's do one more all right all right uh
i heard this mom yelling at her daughter
at like a target
and she was like you slept with that boy
it was like some girl was like 18 or 17.
she's like you slept with that boy
you're such a [ __ ] how long you you've
known him two three days you slept with
him
and she's like you gotta let him take
you out buy you dinner
be up be a decent human being blah blah
i'm like it's so weird that
[ __ ] a guy you want to [ __ ] is more
[ __ ] than
or more [ __ ] than buying letting him
buy you dinner and making him wait
and then buying you more things and
taking you out longer that is what a
prostitute does
literally like just now i probably look
like a super villain right now
oh that's uh that's killer i love it oh
you like that i love that it's my
favorite one so far i mean oh great
it's it's a it's a really
interesting commentary on
on sluttiness yeah cause on whorishness
like
you're describing a prostitute like hey
you gotta use your vagina to get things
what are you crazy you can't give it
away but giving it away is actually the
most progressive thing
yeah it's funny to be like you [ __ ]
him he's like yeah it's like did he at
least get an eggplant parm out of the
whole thing you know like
exactly yeah it's all it's completely
backwards
like that's the symbol of of uh a classy
lady is getting as much
time and money out of your clam as
possible
crazy i like these they progressive in
the next line
you're clam yeah come on your hatchet
wound is a money maker
no but it's funny to be like it's funny
to be like uh
like i [ __ ] this guy you did okay what
did you get
yeah yeah exactly like what did you it's
like it's funny to be like like it's a
heist
right right it's like when they say know
your worth and you're like
what i mean i wanted the [ __ ] guy so
i [ __ ] him
but now you're trying to get me to like
get goods and services out of my
vag yeah that is really funny where
you're like
usually sex is like between two people
that really like each other it's not
like
you're like you're not like i got ripped
off
yeah yeah not a scam exactly
but she's like you got to use it for you
know you got to take advantage of that
thing and take advantage of him and get
stuff out of him
that's what a classy lady does it's
funny when you say you took advantage of
someone
it's like usually it's in a moment of
weakness or something like
you took advantage of that person was
like means they're like on the rebound
or something but in that
setting it's you took advantage means
you just got [ __ ] yeah right right
also when a man takes advantage of a
woman me too
when a woman takes advantage of a man
lobster bisque
nice i mean i don't know that's a great
it's a great line
i always thought it was weird and this
is maybe a separate bit but like
you know you take a girl out and she's
like you're buying me a burger
you know that's it you think you get
anywhere with a burger i'm like oh i
didn't know we were uh
you know doing a sale here like i didn't
know this was a transaction
isn't that weird like a burger and fries
are you thinking of getting these pants
with the burger from like
i thought i'd get in the pants because
you liked me and wanted to hook up with
me
but apparently it's all about how much
yeah i would say what you got to say
after that is like yeah i'm taking you a
burger and fries because i'm expecting
not to [ __ ] you
that's why because you're getting gassed
and bloaty you know that's why i got you
this [ __ ] you know
yeah yeah i'm actually a romantic i'll
take you out for chili tomorrow night i
don't give a [ __ ] you know yeah
i'm trying to get to know you i know
i've been here for the long haul here
all right all right that's funny that's
why women want sushi because you're like
it's light
he's gonna exactly that means sex is
still on the table maybe i don't know
right oh yeah that's true
all right what do you got let's see what
i got i don't have much man
um
hmm man i wear some unfunny premises
down
hit me with a premise i bet we can come
up with something let's see
um these are two these are like just
notes these aren't even premises let's
see what else we got um well your skin
looks great i'm getting
that light set up yeah i i don't have a
light setup it's a lamp
i don't know not a blemish not a cut not
a
zit not a scar nothing
well i try man um i'm coming off a
weekend vendor over here
oh is this funny at all i was talking to
a guy are you you went hard this weekend
oh yeah i was in austin so you got to go
after it
rogan this week yeah yeah we'll see
we'll see what happens oh
uh what do i have okay so i have
here's an idea i had i don't know if
there's anything but my mom was like
she's telling me she's like oh my friend
uh steve's mother passed away and i was
like oh my god that's that's horrible
she was well she was 97
i was like ah so she lived a long life
she goes but she was sick for a long
time i was like just tell me how to feel
and i'll feel it
you know what i mean yeah exactly i
don't know what you want here
sounds like people just take you on
these [ __ ] roller coasters of emotion
i'm just like i just i can't
i like to feel steady yeah i don't like
i don't like
i don't like to do this [ __ ] it's you
know another time people do that is like
you ever just talking to someone they
try to like drag you down where i was
talking to someone once and she goes
how are you especially in this pandemic
people are [ __ ] miserable and misery
likes company so
yep someone talked to yours have you
been and i said i'm doing all right
i'm doing pretty well and she goes yeah
i was like
yeah are you trying to you're trying to
talk me out of it right
she goes okay and i was like okay [ __ ]
you okay
like you don't accept it right ugh i
hate that
i don't like people that try to uh
put you in a mood that are like this is
how you should feel
yes exactly i like control and maybe i'm
giving them too much power
my therapist would say sure but colin
quinn used to have that great joke when
somebody goes uh
how you doing good and you're like well
you just gave me one option
you know you've already how you doing
good
like you just already answered it so why
the [ __ ] are you talking about that's
good
yeah but the the the dead parent thing
or the sick mom whatever
i was on a flight once and uh this
little guy was crying or
like sad next to me and i was like oh
hey and he's like yeah my mom died i'm
going to her funeral and i went oh i'm
sorry he goes did you do it
and i go now and he goes what the hell
are you sorry for i was like
i don't give a [ __ ] about your mom i was
trying to be nice it's yeah it's called
having comp
human compassion yeah like you say it's
what you say that person thinks they're
like roasting you or something like
gotcha did you do it you should have
been like yeah i killed your [ __ ]
[ __ ]
i killed your [ __ ] horn mother that's
what i did go [ __ ] yeah yeah she choked
on my dick
[Laughter]
cuts you getting thrown off of like
a piece of [ __ ] uh your mom's escaped
man
this is [ __ ] wailing on you yeah
i'm like that little asian guy they
dragged off
um that's interesting just tell me how
to feel because uh
i'm doing all this for you here buddy
like your mom i don't know your mom your
mom's sick okay i'm sorry like
i know i'm thinking about a roller
coaster uh yeah my mom also i'm sure
you're dealing with this too you talk to
your parents you're just getting a
[ __ ] list of people that are either
sick or dying oh
it's tough i and like look i i
you try to be like all right [ __ ] yeah
we know we know him too obviously not as
many but sure but it's like a newsletter
now
you know my mom's like oh you remember
terry remember ronnie remember joe
you're like yes yes
all right i just got here i told my mom
watch the news uh it's the obituary
section that's the news
yeah that's all your mom is the obituary
that the weather
is the weather and also like whatever
take your vitamins floss that's
does your mom do that no my dad is a
little my dad's more the health guy
yeah your dad's healthy oh dude my dad
was doing yoga
in like the 80s and i would walk in on
him
a little ironic i'd walk in on him and
say he's like hmm
and i was like daddy's like get the hell
out of here i was like jesus this yoga
is not working
but yeah my dad's a real hell
yeah my dad's keto he's all that [ __ ] oh
he's healthy
oh yeah oh i mean i feel like this is a
good app
right yeah yeah definitely did you want
to say a pet peeve
before we go i feel like those are pet
peeves
yeah what do you got hit me with one
well i had one thing that happened to me
today that i [ __ ] hate
and it's pretty specific but i'm getting
on a flight
so you know you got to show the guy your
boarding pass just to get in the
security line and he looks at it he goes
you know you're boarding pretty soon and
i was like oh what do you mean he's like
well
you're gonna have to hurry up and i'm
like i have a half hour he's like hey
you know you want to push it
that's that's your call like you're
taught you're wasting more of my time
like
what do you want me to be upset that i'm
boarding soon like i know that
get out of here 30 minutes you i'm sure
you got pre-check and [ __ ]
pre-check there's no one at the airport
it's a pandemic like i just hated that
guy
oh do you ever just i mean i remember a
guy [ __ ] with me
so hard i don't know if i ever told you
this story but uh years ago
maybe eight years ago or so gilda's fest
remember that fest
oh yeah that was fun yeah not fun for me
i
i so stupid am i booked a gig on cheapo
air it's called oh yeah it's called
cheapo air
so the connect flight it's like by the
way i should have seen this as a red
flag
the two can i have a connect flight but
they're different airlines which means
if you miss it neither airline
is accountable right right so guess what
i miss
my connect flight and i have to go to
delta and be like hey man
what do i do and the guy is literally
laughing in my face
and i just at a certain point i go [ __ ]
you and he was like why do i go [ __ ] you
i go you're a [ __ ] ass he's making
fun of me and you can tell i'm panicking
and go [ __ ] you so the woman next to me
could see i'm losing my [ __ ] she goes
let me help you thank god i had to buy
583 ticket to grand rapids on the spot
a connect ticket oh brutal
that's this guy's laughing at me as i
walk by go [ __ ] you
it's almost worth it for the [ __ ] it was
worth it was worth it i already had the
ticket i was good to go
but by the way hilarious that you spent
500 plus dollars on a cheapo
air like they got that [ __ ] it's like
when you go spirit and then they're like
okay actually with the bags with the
armrest
with the water with the the seat now
it's 700
oh dude it [ __ ] i lost
my mind what are you gonna do
that's horrible my flair it's my fault
yeah i guess i mean i don't know you
missed the connect that's not on you
that's the flight was delayed i guess
yeah but cheapo is not reliable it's
better than deadbeat air that's where i
got miles with them
uh frugal air i i sometimes go with
you're gonna regret this air
they're pretty bad yeah yeah get your
life together air
you're a [ __ ] vagrant yeah you're a
[ __ ] hobo heir
right you're worthless you're nothing
[ __ ] you
i'm in first class i've got a i've got a
marshmallow roasting over a [ __ ] fire
pit
like come on yeah
500 bucks that's brutal brutal
it's funny how we i think that would
bother me for like a year
but that's probably what seven years ago
you don't even think about it
it still bothers me i don't blame you i
do the same way
this is a hot up man this is fun yeah
yeah i like the new segments what what's
what's that one more drink one more
drink because that's that's what we've
been doing
oh yeah and i i will probably get one
more after this because
i'm jonesing i'm jonesing man this was
hot that's a good ab
good up all right well i'll see you next
week fatty next week